donald trump's completely incompetent
coronavirus advisor dr
scott atlas has now suggested that you
know what
maybe people should should just go ahead
and have the big
indoor thanksgivings this year because
it might be the last thanksgiving
for lots of people anyway now i read the
headline and i thought this can't be
true
it can't actually be that bad let me
look at the video
i then watch the video and it's even
worse than the headline when you
actually
see the complete disregard for human
life
the complete lack of empathy the
complete lack of understanding the video
is
worse than the headline let's take a
look and just as a reminder
who the hell is scott atlas scott atlas
is the doctor
that when trump pushed fauci out from
being sort of publicly part of his inner
coronavirus circle appearing with him as
at press briefings and the like
when fauci was pushed out scott atlas
was brought in now
scott atlas is not an epidemiologist
he's not an
infectious disease doctor he's not a
pulmonologist an immunologist he's
he's a radiologist and he has become
donald trump's top guy on coronavirus
why
because he'll simply go along with
anything donald trump says take a look
at this
they're suffering from with isolation
and this kind of isolation is one of the
unspoken tragedies of the elderly
who are now being told don't see your
family at thanksgiving
for many people this is their final
thanksgiving believe it or not
what are we doing here i think we have
to have a policy which i have been
advocating
which is a whole person whole health
policy
it's not about just stopping cases of
covid
we have to talk about the damage of the
policy itself
so what does the federal government do
it's what i've advised
so that is a neuroradiologist
advocating for things what
this guy is just disgusting and
you know when i want to talk about
infectious disease i don't
typically think to call a radiologist
this is no offense to radiologists
we have a handful of radiologists in our
audience that i know about
we probably have more radiologists in
our audience that i don't know about
two of them actually emailed me and they
said david you know
i don't find it offensive when people
say why the hell is a radiologist
up there on trump's coronavirus task
force so prominently
they wrote to me and said i'm a
radiologist i have no business dictating
public health policy during a global
pandemic period
why is scott atlas doing anything here
is question number one
stanford university which is where scott
atlas was a senior fellow at the hoover
institution
before joining trump's coronavirus team
has already distanced itself from scott
atlas's comments
political observers who have some
connection to reality have been
criticizing scott atlas's presence in
this group
and what scott atlas doesn't seem to be
saying
is that we might make this thanksgiving
the last one for lots of people
if we hold these huge indoor gatherings
which will spread the virus and will
kill people who could have
otherwise had many more thanksgivings
now it's also
sort of strange scott atlas talks about
the elderly some of these elderly folks
might be on their last
thanksgiving regardless of whether
uh there was a pandemic or not remember
that the death rate for coronavirus
triples for those in their 60s relative
to those in their 50s
and then the death rate almost triples
again
for those in their 70s relative to those
in their 60s
people in their 50s 60s and 70s often
live a long time like
if you're 59 and you have a
significantly higher death rate
than those under 50. when he says the
elderly might be dying in the next year
anyway is he talking about 59 year olds
is he talking about 65 year olds is he
talking about 75 or like what is he even
talking about here when he says
this may be the last thanksgiving anyway
for lots of these folks
who are at higher risk if they contract
coronavirus
delusional completely delusional
and this is the doctor who has trump's
ear if you say well
there's all these different people who
are doing good work uh
um peter hotez and you know dr anthony
fauci
and our friend isaac bogash who's in
canada i mean
the point is there's so many doctors
doing good work and talking sense here
and it's scott atlas who has donald
trump's ear
once again it's the worst people i
previously said
almost any random american would have
better handled coronavirus than trump
and you might be wondering well like how
would a construction worker
or an accountant or a preschool teacher
or a dental hygienist like how what do
you mean
how would they have handled it better
than trump most people would not be so
delusional
delusionally narcissistic that they
would think they know more than doctors
most people would just say wow i'm in
charge of the pandemic great
what kind of doctors and public health
officials and scientists know about
pandemics
let's turn it over to them and you would
end up with a better situation than what
we ended up with
trump did worse than random people
by imposing his ignorance and his
delusions and his narcissism on the
situation
you are seeing the same thing now with
dr scott atlas almost any doctor would
better handle this
my dentist who has been my dentist since
i was five years old
if you put my dentist in charge my
dentist would immediately say
great let's bring in an epidemiologist
let's bring in a public health expert
let's bring in an infectious disease
expert a pulmonologist a medical ethic
you know whatever
you guys tell me what to do what to say
and we'll get it done any one of the
doctors on joe biden's coronavirus task
force even oncologist and medical
ethicist
zeke emanuel would better handle this
than the combination of scott atlas and
donald trump
they regularly find the worst people
to do the absolute worst things all the
time like clockwork and remember
one of the selling points about donald
trump
was this is a businessman sort of like a
project manager he'll hire the best
people
he'll put the best people in charge and
it's all going to be fantastic
there were very few even ostensible
selling points about donald trump the
ones that there were were bogus
he's failed on every single one of them
including famously i will hire the best
people and put the best people in in
positions of power
we will be lucky to now get out of this
with under you know for we're looking at
400 000
americans dead by february maybe even
more we will be lucky to keep the
numbers that low and at one point
remember donald trump said
forget about 15 cases will soon be zero
at one point when this was
a thing donald trump was saying we we
might lose 50 or 60 000 people but it's
not going to be more than that we're
looking at 400 000 maybe even half a
million
let me know where you are on the next
three months of the virus
via twitter where you can find me at d
pacman
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number
the privacy app and the browser plug-in
let you give each company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create
out of thin air it'll even auto fill the
card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be because you
can destroy
the virtual card number right after
using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity
private by not telling companies who you
are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected against data breaches and
identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want
privacy also offers a ten dollar a month
plan that gives you one percent cash
back and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a 25
a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create
60 card numbers a month and much more
but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up at
privacy.com pacman